foreign
I've never been much of a kid person
it's just never been a plan for my life
but here I am really really crazy about
a person that has two kids how do I go
forward being a part of these kids lives
if he and I are going to stay together
you said you don't like him I can't
believe he would be with someone who
doesn't like his kid
[Music]
it's John with a Dr John delone show
greatest mental health and marriage and
podcasts
created in the history of Earth
and the medium which is about a year and
a half old how old are podcasts 10 years
15 years
well we were doing it when I started
here and that was over 10 years ago so I
think closer to probably 15 15 20. hmm
maybe I should take a class on the
history of podcasts that class is
probably coming up soon hey I'm so glad
that you joined us and on the show we
tell the truth we walk alongside each
other and we try to figure out what
comes next
um if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask and don't forget
um as you're planning for New Year's
go pick up a whoop strap man
go pick it up everybody in there has got
one now it's awesome it helps you track
your stuff and don't forget if you're
gonna start considering making some
changes in your health go to thorn.com
you slash deloni
um to pick up your supplements killer
deal
um for everybody here it's not for us to
make money it's to help you guys out
um really want you guys to consider
being healthier in the upcoming year all
right let's go to Ashley and Coeur
d'Alene what's up Ashley
hi Dr John thank you how are you
uh other than losing my voice this
morning I'm good excellent well I'm
sometimes people who are around me wish
I would lose my voice so it's good to
talk to you it's good to talk to you so
what's up
um Okay so
July of 2021
um I met a guy
um he was pretty upfront with me in the
beginning
that he was still married
um and that he was going through uh the
divorce process
and that was actually one of the things
that bonded Us in the beginning
um because I had just finalized a
divorce in February earlier that year
um so here's where I have to be really
honest
I've never been much of a kid person
my ex-husband and I we never wanted kids
and it's just never been a plan for my
life
um but here I am really really crazy
about a person that uh has two kids
um he has an almost 12 year old daughter
and a four and a half year old boy
um unfortunately their mom has made
things really super difficult through
their divorce process
um and both because the divorce isn't
final yet
um she's drug their daughter into
her mess of emotions they're still
married Ashley
okay so she's
oh geez
Okay so
the mom is telling her things you know
Ashley is the reason that your dad left
us
um Ashley stole you from us or stole
your dad from us
um so as you can imagine the 12 year old
wants nothing to do with me
um they've legally been separated for
two years before I was in the picture
um so I just tried giving the daughter a
ton of grace and patience and not being
too too pushy
uh just being present when when she's
around
um and then the four-year-old
he's pretty difficult he's just a
difficult child and in general
um my boyfriend he's a pretty absent dad
due to his job and he's he just doesn't
really know how to parent he's absent
because he's a coward
this whole call is about a lack of
respect you don't respect this guy and
you shouldn't
and his ex-wife or his still wife should
not be talking bad about you or him or
any other adults to a 12 year old she's
in the wrong there yes but she shouldn't
just welcome you with open arms because
that's still her husband
right and has been for a couple of years
so you don't respect this guy y'all TR
y'all bonded over
both being in a mess at the same time
and coming out of a mess he's still
squirrely in it but you were coming out
of a mess and it feels really good when
somebody looks at you and goes yeah me
too
yes and that can have a a
it can feel a lot like love
when you look across a room and your
body recognizes that that guy gets it he
understands
this is how almost every Affair in the
world starts with uh two people who work
together at work and one of them goes
man my husband's really been tough and
he goes
ah man my wife's struggling too and now
we have a shared misery together and it
it's like a pseudo connection it's not
real
right
I don't
I mean tell me I I interrupted what can
I do to help I mean this just sounds
like a mess
it it is
my question is just how do I go forward
being a part of these kids lives if he
and I are gonna stay together
I mean
you said you don't like them
I can't believe he would be with so I
can't believe a lot of things about this
dude I can't believe he would be with
someone who doesn't like his kids
it's not that I don't like his kids I
never pictured like be being a stepmom
being like in that
in that role I know but yeah you
accepted it
right so either you get real serious
about
um
like if you had no vehicle in the world
to drive none and somebody handed you a
stick shift truck
you know like this is a car it's a truck
it's free for you to use you would get
very serious about learning how to drive
a standard because you would have to
if you wanted to choose to go to work
and you want to choose to pay rent and
choose to eat right and so similarly
you've are going to go along with this
fantasy for a little while longer and
say that I love this guy I want to be
with him
um
even though he hasn't proven trustworthy
to his ex-wife he said not a good dad
he's not a person of character integrity
at this moment and but I love him good
good for you
by doing that you have also accepted the
role as I'm inheriting two kids one is
about to be a teenager who's been
through absolute hell
and one is a four-year-old who has never
known stability or peace at home
I'm choosing to enter into that which
means you've got to get Defcon 1 serious
about learning how to parent being in
relationship with taking classes getting
some other women in your life that have
joined Blended families going to
counseling and therapy regularly
that's what you're signing up for by
being with this guy you cannot divorce
him from his kids
okay it's it's it's evil it's unethical
yeah no that's I would not want to do
that and
like can we man can we just be like you
don't respect him do you
I don't respect how he is as a parent no
do you respect how he's handled his
marriage
but when he's still in
um that's that's a whole nother story to
get into
um just just yes or no
foreign
why have you trapped yourself in the
it's this guy or bust it's all these
other things that I didn't have
envisioned in my life
but I'm attached to this guy
Inc
I was with my ex-husband for 10 years
my entire 20s
I met him when I was 20 we divorced when
I was 30.
why did y'all divorce
um he was an alcoholic and I
banged my head against the wall for lots
of years trying to get him to
stop drinking okay you're heading you're
heading directly into that same storm
with just a different drug
really
yeah I mean
yeah you've gotta you've got a guy who's
not he hasn't decided who or where he
wants to be he hasn't done the hard work
of determining what it's going to take
to get there and he's taken no steps
he's got no disciplines left to go get
there
at any point in the last four years you
accelerate you cash out I'm not gonna
fight for the money anymore I'm gonna
concede a weekend I'm gonna end this
marriage orem's gonna keep putting it
along for four years five years six
years and by the way it doesn't even
matter I'm already dating I'm already
seriously dating somebody else
I'm not going to be with my kids I'm not
going to do the things a single dad has
to do
to make sure my kids are stable and okay
I'm just going to my next drug of choice
which is work
and I'll just work and I'll work and
I'll be busy and my kids won't know
their dad but I'll send a check home
that's what he's done
he's done it's a drug he's an alcoholic
he just does it at work
and in our culture alcoholics
get DWIs and they go to rehab and we
give people addicted to their jobs a
million dollars and say good job
all right and they burn everybody in
their world to the ground
because everyone ends up asking from
their spouse to their kids to their
friends huh
what's wrong with what's so bad about me
that I'm not more important than that
email or that meeting
or couldn't you just make that a phone
call why do you got to go out of town
for that
yeah and this is an addict talking to an
addict
I'm a absolute workaholic I have a
problem with it
so much so that my work now when we're
before I take on a big project they ask
my wife
because they want me to be in this long
term and they care about me and my
family
so you're trading you're you are
entering into the same thing again
and I don't want to beat the guy up man
he's clearly got some demons he's
wrestling with I'd love to sit down and
just say bro what are you doing man
because his life is worth more than what
he's cranking out of it too
foreign
here's your path forward
being very very clear about two things
what do you want Ashley you get one shot
man
hit one shot what do you want
and then the second thing is what are my
boundaries what am I going to accept
what am I not going to accept
and all the research I've read and
seeing all the people I've met with over
the years
I've never seen a relationship is
sustained that doesn't have mutual
respect in it
where people wake up and they're like I
I don't even like what that guy does but
I respect it gets up and grinds it out
every day I can't stand this guy's boss
I don't like the way her employees treat
her man she gets after it every day
there's just a sense of of respect
right
and ultimately
we talk about pictures you had in your
head you didn't think you were going to
be here at 32 or 33 or 34 did you
no no not at all yeah
so at some point you have to make peace
here's what has happened up until now
there's a period at the end of those
sentences and right now you're trying to
edit those sentences
in real time and you can't they've
already been written it's over
you got divorced when you were 30. I'm
gonna own that
crap happened between 20 and 30 some of
that was on me some of that was I stuck
around way too long I loved too much
some of that was
the person I was married to was a mess
all it is it happened and the only thing
you can do now is ask yourself that one
terrifying question what am I gonna do
now
am I just gonna cash out and accept what
comes next cool
I for one think your life is worth not
actually
and I'm not saying go break up with this
Duty maybe it just works out I I
he's still married is all I'm saying he
can tell you any story he wants to
but just out of the gate this thing's
rough I want you to hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of my book own
your past change your future I want you
to read it cover to cover give it to him
as well
then ask yourself the questions at the
end of some of the chapters do the
exercises and I want you to get to the
end ask yourself okay
what am I going to do now
and if you stay involved with this dude
you better plug directly into those kids
man
and you better be real clear with him
about your boundaries and who you're
gonna be in a relationship moving
forward
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement an MLs ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back hey before
it's call it is questions for Human
season good people get online go to John
deloney.com and get these friendship
marriage parenting and holiday
relationship Savers that's what they are
questions for humans we've got new packs
out for couples
we've got new packs for friends for
parents and kids uh my daughter this
morning she's six and uh she was reading
them on her bed I said what are you
doing and she just looked up and as
though she'd been caught doing something
and she said can I just ask these and
answer them in my head and I was like
you can do whatever you want to all the
voices in her head they're playing
questions for you man this is so good so
hey they're incred like they're so good
and I don't want to like be that guy
that's bragging but I I can't tell you
all over the country I'm traveling and
people are coming out and being like
dude I got these questions that they
were so dumb they're like 10 or 15 bucks
I bought them I was like oh gosh
I learned more about my wife and this is
someone who's been married 40 years
someone's married 20 years somebody's
been married two years I learned more
about my wife and whenever we learn more
about each other she thought that was
going on and then so I'm telling you I'm
telling you questions for humans man all
right here's two new new decks for this
year if you've listened to the show for
a while you know I am obsessed with New
Year's I love it I love the fact that we
all get a mulligan and no matter what's
going on like man I really got into some
hard stuff this year it's cool man New
Year's it we all just are like that's
cool control alt delete let's do
something else and so I got one for New
Year's it's it's fun it's for hanging
out before New Year's and it's also for
planning for New Year's what are we
gonna do this upcoming year who are we
going to be and Christmas Christmas
cards these things are very limited
because obviously it's Christmas and
they are flying out of here and that's
not me just saying that we're selling a
bajillion of them and I hope that
they're still available but when this
episode airs please get online and get
these uh I'm gonna ask a few questions
to the gang in the bwoth all right you
ready
uh I'm just gonna here we go let's see
here horse noise just returned uh um
let's see here
what Christmas tradition do you want to
start
um I think for me I want to start
because my parents never let us do this
open one CR one present on Christmas Eve
because my parents never let me do that
um Mom I'm talking to you uh so I would
love to start doing where we can open
one present oh small all good Traditions
begin from a rejection of our previous
cultural Morris good job
Benjamin I would like to adapt something
that my wife's family does for birthdays
which is when they go around in a circle
and say something they love about the
person whose birthday it is I would love
to do that for Christmas just like
have one thing go around in a circle and
say one thing they love about the other
person does that get all mushy and gross
oh yeah my family totally doesn't do
that and so it's been weird like
I'm so grateful for you and you go to
the next house and you're like hey be
quiet pasta queso basically that's
incredible
Kelly I don't mean my kids are teenagers
so we kind of feel like we have ours
kind of set
um
how very old person of you I know but
you know when you have little kids and
you kind of the way I do it it's right
right now that's just how it is let's
make Christmas great again Kelly
well thanks for that I think that
um one that I would like to start I
would like to start the tradition of the
kids helping me
cook Christmas dinner that would be a
great tradition Wow Let's Start pawning
off responsibilities among others I like
it I like it I'm in yeah being more
involved in because a lot of times it's
just the four of us for Christmas Day
because
um we don't travel you hate your family
that's fine no we we've set a rule a
long time ago we don't travel at
Christmas yeah
um if you want to see us we will be at
our house that's way and nobody comes no
about every other year about like last
year my in-laws were there they should
they'll be with another one gotcha um
but that's the way that my dad did it
Santa comes to our house and that's
where he comes I love it and so but I
would like for it to be more of a now
the kids are a little older everybody
chipping in and helping and kind of you
know instead of them sitting there doing
nothing and me working hour you know for
many hours to make dinner so here's
here's mine and it's it's uh off of a
Christmas tradition that had when I was
a kid
um I think it was 15 or 16 and there was
this club this punk rock club downtown
it was an old blues Club it turned into
kind of a more Punk Rock Club called
Fitzgerald's in downtown Houston and
every Christmas Christmas Day a band
called 30 foot fall would play the best
the best
and I was 15 or 16 we heard they were
playing and so we opened presents and
did the whole thing and then me and one
of my buddies went down there and
watched the show
fast forward
20 years they played every Christmas Day
and I would drive home in college I
would drive home I'm fairly certain I
was the only dean of students at a
faith-based university in that audience
as an old man like we were kids used to
be like there's always one old guy and I
remember being like Oh no that's me I
brought my wife before we got married I
was like hey I'm I got married I got
engaged on January 6th I took her to the
Christmas show I was like you got to get
through this and it was a lot and she
smiled a whole time anyway
I I want to have some sort of that with
my son with Hank and one day with
Josephine but it'd be fun to be like hey
it's Mark show day and then him be like
oh Dad I don't want to go but I can't
would love that it's not ever gonna
happen but that would be cool all right
what Christmas movie gets way too much
hype
and if you say die hard you can't work
on the show anymore
I am not a fan of It's a Wonderful Life
I know all the positivity and joy and
lessons yeah that's not my thing gross
it's sort of like a version of seven for
Christmas or something that I could
watch
I love Christmas music Christmas movies
love them love them love them but that
one just is not just real yeah Benjamin
all right I'm gonna get hate mail for
this I'm gonna say elf
wow it's it's okay you are welcome to
leave you're welcome to leave
Jenna Christmas story I don't think I've
ever actually seen it all the way
through I've only seen bits and pieces
of it and it's just it looks boring we
need a new team we need a new team
clearly what is happening I know see I
love a Christmas what's your favorite
Christmas movie A Christmas Story
uh probably White Christmas
I love that one it's so good oh that's
beautiful uh elf is mine but white
Christmas is fantastic Nightmare Before
Christmas is mine that's not a Christmas
movie though oh that's a Halloween it
has Christmas in it yeah but it's
straight too more Halloween themed like
he they torture Santa well that sounds
like Santa should have represented a
little bit more
that's all I'm saying hey questions for
humans
there is no questions about politics no
questions about covid no questions about
anything other than fun stuff to get to
know the people that you love and you
care about or people you're trying to
get to know so that you can love them
you know all right so go to John
deloney.com and pick up questions for
humans get them all get them all they're
a blast all right let's go to Tim in
Huntsville Alabama what's up Tim
hey Dr John how's it going good man hey
Alabama's hit on Hard Times man
yeah I'm I've had a chance to really
watch much football
I think that's probably that's probably
better for you yeah exactly all right so
what's up man
well uh um my question is kind of
pertaining to me and my wife and our
relationship and boundaries between uh
her sister and her boyfriend
your wife doesn't have a boyfriend
no her her sister has a boyfriend the
way you said you said between my sister
my between me and my wife and her sister
and her boyfriend I was like whoa yeah
okay so it's not not full Alabama all
right all right all right all right okay
so your your wife has a sister and your
wife's sister has a boyfriend okay
correct yes all right so bring it okay
um so I love my wife I feel like I'm
married to my best friend absolutely
adore her
um my mother-in-law and father-in-law
are awesome human beings they're so
supportive and generous
um but wait till it comes to but
yeah
um uh my wife's sister uh has was an
alcoholic early on in her life and that
really caused some problems with
um her relationship with my sister okay
and with her parents obviously
um and there's been a string of like
very bad decisions uh that led to those
strange relationships be specific man
she's stealing stuff is she like she
apparently got violent with my sister a
couple of times
um
basically completely disrespected any
rules that the parents had in the house
um I just hung out with the wrong people
but uh thankfully uh now she's been
sober for several years awesome and uh
she's got a job she's doing really well
herself
um but her boyfriend is a bit uh I I
call it like immature
um he struggles keeping a job
and kind of in in my opinion kind of
like mooches off of her
and is more like a child to her I guess
than an actual partner okay and they
live together
um but the whole dynamic here is where
the problem kind of arose with us is
we live uh in a central location between
the two so mother and father-in-law live
about two hours north of us
sister-in-law and brother or
sister-in-law and boyfriend
live about four hours south of us so
we're Central you're going to move to
the family you gotta move
this is going to fall on you forever you
don't want him coming to stay with you
huh
yeah that's that's the thing and so me
and my wife we're uh very adamant about
our standards and our virtues we believe
that you know sex is only for marriage
and we shouldn't
um live together in a cohabitation
unless we're actually married okay and
we don't agree with what uh her sister
and boyfriend are doing but hold on hold
on has she invited you in for your
opinion
no she hasn't no okay I would spend zero
seconds for the rest of my life
considering that
oh yeah I definitely I definitely agree
like what they do in their own house
that's completely 100 up to them yeah uh
the problem that uh and I may be making
too big of a deal out of this but uh
they want to have Christmas at our house
because oh do you know what I'm sharing
a room
yeah that's that's kind of the thing and
on on my argument is if they want to
stay under our Roof then they would have
to stay in separate rooms my wife is
kind of split because
she sees
that aspect of it but we also want to
preserve the relationship there we don't
want to push them away
after these past few years where there's
been some healing in the relationship
there so let's let me let's back out of
this situation okay
um number one I appreciate you laying it
all out there okay that's awesome
um
I love hamburgers and I love barbecue
and I
um eat a ton of wild game it's just how
our family does things okay we also have
chickens and we eat eggs every day
yeah I also have a couple of friends who
I love and care about and they are Die
Hard vegans to the death I guess not to
the deaf to the death of the spinach
right no other deaths
I don't
show up with burgers at their house
because it's disrespectful it's rude
yeah and if I'm gonna go stay there and
they're gonna have dinner I don't say
Hey man can I bring it because I because
I don't because I'm wanna be better than
that my friendship to them is more
important than that okay
so I tell you that to tell you this
it's your home
and it's your boundaries
and it's your values
they as people visiting your home
get to make their choice
whatever that happens to be hey we just
don't believe in air conditioning
and that's just how we roll we just
don't believe in it you are welcome to
um
here's my buddy Todd came and stayed at
my house Todd would prefer that most of
his life he lived on Antarctica and in
on Antarctica in Antarctica
um he prefers the temperature when he's
sleeping to be about negative six and in
our house sounds like my kind of guy
yeah exactly I had about 65. he when he
stayed at my house it was great and he
took a mattress out of the guest room
and Drug it into like another room where
it was cooler and you know what I didn't
care and he didn't care he chose to stay
at my house and he knows that we don't
have it sub-arctic we just have it cold
right all that to say is this they're
visiting your house
they get to decide are we going to come
in with this set of rules if you start
compromising your values whatever they
may be
in this pseudo-protective trying to
preserve a relationship
where the whole thing ends up is in
resentment Ash
okay
so
I how old are you
I'm 28.
my my
here's where here's the one thing I'm
struggling with
is I feel maybe I'm out to lunch and
maybe it's just uh the way you and I
just we just communicate differently but
it feels like there's a
superiority
and I would let the air out of that
um
you have might not have been an
alcoholic but I promise you've had your
struggles and you might not be a mooch
but I promise that there are ways you
could be a better and more connected
husband right so I would get rid of the
um my values are better than their
values okay
I would say
stick with your values whatever they may
be who cares they're yours it's your
house
and let other adults make their choices
whether they want to opt into those they
can also get a hotel they can also go
camping they can also laugh and make fun
of you and be like that's so dumb but
okay
and all is well
you see what I'm saying
if they choose
to not come then they have chosen not to
come
that should not impact your value
judgments
see what I'm saying
yeah yeah that makes sense
so I'm not gonna dude if you said we
don't walk on the carpet in my house
well I don't take my shoes off well now
we got a problem you get to choose
whether you come in my house or not
I don't believe that people who aren't
married should sleep in the same bed
cool
well I'm my girlfriend and I are coming
over to your house well you've got a
choice to make
see what I'm saying like I just want to
take all the air out of the drama
like I'm just I'm just not gonna
apologize for my values in my house
yeah and and that's kind of what I told
my wife is
if
if it was a value we would apply to our
future children say I feel like it would
apply to ourselves
anyone who comes to visit us like we
should be consistent not change the
rules for whoever
enters you know
if that's how y'all want to roll with it
man don't give it a second thought
okay and let the other adults in your
life make their choices
um they get to do that and expect people
to when they run up against your
boundaries and I've said this a million
times when they run up against your
boundaries they're gonna bang their head
on them they're gonna kick and scream
they're gonna yell and punch and kick
and see if those boundaries hold
and man I'm just not gonna lose sleep
over this is just who we are in our
house
um I've recently done some interviews
with people that
um people don't like
I actually got both sides of the aisle
and one of my core core values is
I'm always gonna have a conversation
with somebody
just as people I believe they have that
dignity and that right to have a
conversation I'm not above anybody and
so people are going to get to make their
choices I'm not going to listen to drone
anymore because he had a conversation
with so and so he was on somebody else's
show he did this that's knock your
lights out that's great
but as for me and my house we're people
who are hospitable and we have
conversations with everybody
because I got a lot to learn I'm still
figuring this thing out
so Tim don't apologize for your for your
boundaries be very clear be very direct
and be very respectful you're not better
than you were with right not lording
over but with and hold firm
to who you and your wife want your home
to represent who you're going to be and
be prepared to live with the
consequences of your values all values
have consequences you're in the right
place my brother we'll be right back
hey it's Dr John deloney here look
people are always saying the holidays
are the most wonderful time of the year
right for some of us the holidays are
great some of us the holidays are not
great but for all of us the holidays are
Mayhem you're probably traveling all
over the place talking to family members
you didn't even ask for by the way
shopping trying to deal with all the
parties and no one will turn off the
Christmas music you know who you are but
inside the chaos you still have a choice
the choice to take care of yourself and
the best way to navigate the chaos of
the holidays is to make sure you are
well and being well starts with a good
night's sleep and I found that good
sleep starts with a great mattress and
that's why my family sleeps on dream
Cloud dream Cloud mattresses combination
of gel memory foam and coil technology
keeps you comfortable all night and
right now dream cloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners 599 in accessories plus an
additional 250 dollar discount that's
849 dollars in accessories and savings
visit dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloni to get your new mattress and
start getting the rest your body needs
all right we're back let's go out to San
Francisco talk to Daniel what's up
Daniel
hey Dr John how's it going good man what
up good I'm doing great
good well thanks for taking my call
um I'll just jump right into it and I
think there might be a little bit of
crossover from uh the last caller but
interesting to get your take on on me
and my wife's situation as well cool so
we are expecting our first baby early
next year
are you excited
oh yeah I'm pumped I'm actually sitting
in the nursery right now boy girl boy
dude congratulations man
yeah so with that obviously comes lots
of new experiences uh new challenges new
choices
um and love to get your thoughts on a
conversation that we haven't had yet but
that we know is coming and we want to
make sure we handle it well it has to do
with uh with both of our parents um and
um you know the choice to baptize or not
in the church that we grew up in and
that our parents are still very active
in so it's a little bit of a hot button
issue but want to get your your take on
on maybe what are some of the best ways
to go about that I would say it is a hot
button issue and it's not really
yeah on the surface yeah very similar to
Alaska on the surface
um
y'all have been to you and your wife
have been together you've both had your
independent experiences and for
whatever reasons you've landed where
you've landed okay we want to go to a
different church we don't want to go to
church at all we're not really want to
be making decisions for our kid this
early or we are going to do this at this
age but we're going to go to a different
building whatever whatever the reasons
are you've landed there
I think this is an incredible time
for you and your wife to spend some time
both dreaming and being very specific
about your boundaries on a host of
issues
because everybody's gonna have an
opinion when you have a baby your your
parents her parents have already
imagined what their role is going to be
they've already imagined that they're
going to be in the delivery room and
your wife's like yeah they're for sure
not they've already imagined that like
I'm gonna come over and cook dinner and
you're like no you're not you're good so
right so what are those boundaries going
to be you're going to leave your baby
you're gonna like what like that sounded
bad are you gonna like are you gonna let
uh family come over and keep your child
while y'all go to a movie or something
right let's have some of these
conversations and one of the big ones is
going to be how are we going to deal
with our
Faith Heritage and how's that going to
interact with our faith moving forward
if you have you all decided we're not
going to baptize our kid or we are but
we're not going to do it in this
particular building like what does that
look like for y'all
yeah I think we've kind of come to the
decision that we're not gonna do the
same Faith practice that we grew up with
and that we were married in and that you
know is what we know but we do want to
have some sort of Christian principles
and we're sort of in the middle of
exploring you know which you know
denomination Community what have you is
actually most aligned to sort of our
overall you know the way we see the
world and what we see is is you know
going to be the best for for our family
and our community so we're still working
through that a little bit and and I
think mostly where the the question
comes from and you know listen to a lot
of your stuff I sort of anticipated that
might be what you say but there's been
sort of more and more as we get closer
and closer to the birth
um more sort of subtle hints and you
know little comments here and there you
know and inviting us to you know talks
at their church more than they would
have ever before
um kind of things that sort of you know
tip the Caps that like okay it's coming
they haven't flat out asked us yet or
brought anything to the head but you
know it's it's coming and I would say
absent clarity
um like without Clarity and without very
clear boundaries it feels like an
external invasion
they don't have any guidelines and so
what the only guideline they have is
this is happening
we raised you all this way y'all were
married this way you got a kid coming
and dude we're just not here like are we
missing the date or right they're making
the story about them because they have
no other information to go on
and so I this hope this isn't a
controversial statement good grief
um
I really really deeply
honor the faith traditions of
my friends and family who've gone before
me
and you have to understand that there
may be some or all depending on what
faith and what practice we're talking
about here who will see your lack your
decision to not baptize your kid in this
particular denomination
as
a move into eternity
right
like the soul of their grandchild might
be at stake here
and so I think it's fair to give people
with that type of weight permission to
grieve and be sad
because it's not just a perfunctory like
it's not just like hey we get haircuts
it's not that
it's like man you gotta do this or your
Eternal Soul is in danger
see what I'm saying like there is a
weight to that
and so I think having your
um having your beliefs and practices
awesome
be very clear and very respectful be
very direct and understand that the
blowback is bigger than somebody not
getting their way
does that make sense
it does I think one thing that we're
also just trying to be you know
conscious and aware of is you know
especially on on one side the the
familial connection to that you know
belief Heritage is is really strong so
it's really not only gonna you know
impact our relationship with
our parents in in a in some way but will
also probably impact the way that they
are seen amongst the rest of their
family or the rest of the way the rest
of their family sees us right and what
you have to do is you have to let adults
be adults
and you have to make your value
judgments and you have to
control the only two things on Earth you
can control your thoughts and your
actions and here's here's what we're
gonna ask how we're gonna act is what
we're gonna do
and then as adults they get the right to
respond however they need to
and that might be them deciding well
then we're not in a relationship with
you anymore and that will be
heartbreaking and that will be ugly and
that will be messy but that's their
choice that they are making to leave you
and they're going to tell all their
friends that our kids opted out of
relationship with us
because this was the standard we set
and so all like I said in the last call
all values have consequences all of them
do
yeah right do you have any do you have
any advice for maybe how to have that
would you recommend having that
conversation earlier when we're still
sort of in the murky kind of unsure
phase or maybe trying to hold off until
we've got a little bit more clarity on
exactly where we're going what we're
doing
um I think an invitation to ambiguity
will create a mess
meaning
um if you call and ask their opinion
they're going to give it to you then
they're going to be really disheartened
when you don't listen to it
right
yeah be much better to go forward and
say here's what I think here's where we
are here's the choices that we're making
okay but if
they've made a decision where or you
don't know exactly where we're going but
we know we're not going here is that
useful to have earlier to you know let
them process or yeah I don't see any I
don't know another any other way around
that is dishonest because you're letting
them believe that
um they're just waiting at the door for
you guys and you all know now you're not
going there
and people listening will say they don't
even have it right who cares and no we
all care because we love them and we
want to be people of respect and
kindness I think you might be surprised
when they when you say hey we are
interested in trying out different Faith
communities we're going to go to a
couple others we're going to hold off on
the baptism in that whole process for a
season
um while we try to find a new home
church that's going to be for our entire
family
and we love and respect how you guys
raised us and we love that you all have
a place that you go home both in the
present and in eternity if that's what
they believe great but as for our house
we are going to run a look look out and
um we haven't abandoned our faith or
maybe you have like we're moving on from
that right now whatever the thing is to
be very very clear and don't for a
second hint that you're inviting them
into their input
right
yeah and if they're parents they're
going to give you their input let them I
don't I don't care you know what I mean
I I I don't care
and they might tell you yeah we did the
same thing when we were younger
or we wish we had asked more questions
when we were kids
or we think y'all are crazy you're
putting the soul of our grandchild at
stake we're gonna have to take some time
apart like you don't know what's gonna
happen
what I do know is this if you all go
through with some things that you
fundamentally disagree with that you're
opposed to
and you do it to try to appease other
people
it's going to make the next Thanksgiving
really hard to be involved with together
it's going to make the next Christmas
very awkward
it's going to make the show up pop-up
visit have some extra weight to it and
now we're on the pathway to resentment
and it's not going to be their fault
it's going to be y'all didn't set up the
boundaries that you knew to be right for
y'all at the beginning
okay
okay so there is no way to do this where
it's not hard
there is no way to do this where they
don't take it as a sign that you are not
only rejecting their faith but you're
rejecting them
okay that's just gonna be part of this
conversation
and if it's what you and your wife have
agreed is best for your family and for
your new baby then hold your head up
high State your values clearly and your
intentions clearly and be respectful as
people grieve and they need some space
does that make sense I think that makes
sense it's just not an easy way around
it but the only way around the only way
on the other side of this thing is to go
right through it
yeah I'm hoping once that happens you
know they've always been respectful of
our other choices that you know first
grandchild you know it's one of those
big big oh dude yes yes big life moments
so it's it's always heightened around it
so absolutely I appreciate your take no
you got it man and I appreciate you guys
thinking through these things and by the
way the faith issue isn't going to be
the only one
bedtimes feeding routines sleep routines
um how much how involved you are versus
how much you're at work how involved she
is is she gonna go back to work all of
those things you're going to get input
on oh my gosh you're gonna get input
again there's the stupidest advice ever
you're gonna get some great wisdom from
people
start deciding now a what are our values
on this side of the birth and they all
change whenever the baby actually shows
up nobody's gonna keep my kid I'm never
letting anyone come I don't need a
babysitter and then like three weeks and
you're like oh gosh I will hand this kid
off to the mailman if I can just sleep
for the you know for a few hours so
you'll have all these ideas more
importantly is come up with a plan for
how you and your wife are going to stay
connected and actually dig into these
issues when they come up because it's
going to show up around prom it's going
to show up around what school they're
going to go to it's going to show up
around are we gonna let our kids have
social media or not all these things are
just part of Parenthood come up with a
with a structure a plan for not the
final answers but how are we going to
engage in these hard conversations we're
going to go on a date we're gonna go on
a retreat we're gonna go get breakfast
together we're gonna do a thing together
how are we going to continually come
back to one another and say all right we
got a new one how are we gonna figure
this thing out
and that is carving a path that your
kids will walk your grandkids will walk
you're going to be people who don't run
from anxiety you don't run from hard
problems
but you join hands and you turn and face
them and you walk directly through the
middle of
that my brothers where healing comes
from for you for your family for our
entire country
it's banding together and saying here
comes the storm let's walk directly into
it together we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
man right above the Sun that is tattooed
on Kelly's lower back she has a picture
like like a full picture of this next
artist it's an amazing tattoo super
awkward but she is the world's biggest
Mariah Carey fan
the strange tattoo but it is what it is
and it's her favorite song actually
Mariah Carey's All I Want For Christmas
is you and it goes like this I don't
want a lot for Christmas there's just
one thing I need I don't care about the
presents underneath the Christmas tree
I just want you for my own more than you
could ever know making my wish come true
All I Want For Christmas
is you
[Music]
I'm using this
[Music]
but that's not really true I want a
couple of guitars and a new car I want
several things
I guess in YouTube hey we'll see you
soon America thank you
[Music]